our next story shows that a mother's
love truly knows no bounds miles harris
is a reporter at our affiliate station
abc 6 in columbus ohio and he was
covering a story when his mom sandy
drove by and couldn't resist saying
hello the clip went so viral more than
eight million views watch this if you
haven't seen it already
is it
because it's my mom hold on
i'm trying to work right now you order
calling my phone this is the answer
though you can say hi
and don't be holding up traffic cause
you got cars behind you
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
i'm so thrilled that you would come here
and do the show we all were passing this
clip around our own little news team
it was everywhere everyone i know was
talking about this clip what did that
feel when it went viral what did that
feel like honestly it's just so crazy to
think about it um
you never know like a video like this is
going to go viral especially like just
me and my mom just being ourselves we're
really just being ourselves all of our
internal family and friends are just
like this is so much like you guys a
relationship and you know that now not
just our friends and family but now the
world knows how cool of a mom she is do
you think your mom can contain it no i
can't control sandy there's no chance in
that
i can't control sandy sandy is her own
person we're our own relationship but
like um no it's not it was kind of i
wouldn't say the word embarrassing but
just you know my mom's just super happy
to see me like kind of going from where
we've been and kind of moving our way up
and just
doing all that and just she wants the
front row seat my mom's my number one
cheerleader so any time she gets come on
um and you know gosh i wish
every mom could be here right now you
know i was sure mom could do a drive
drive-by right this very second
yeah and give her give one of her cute
hellos when they did that on they did
that we did that on saturday one day and
then on sunday um the anchors caught
wind of it and they're like you have to
post this on social media and then all
during our newscast they're like trying
to tease like hey i wonder if sandy's
going to show up oh
they're like telling us what street
we're on we're doing all that stuff and
they're all playing along well your mom
couldn't get off work to be here with us
but will you look at the camera and just
send her a message and say hi to her
yeah um well first of all obviously i
love you um this is wouldn't be done
without you this whole situation and
being able to show the world just how
amazing you truly are
[Applause]
don't cry there's quality
get it all nice and cozy for you thank
you
sandy i'm i'm so thrilled to see you oh
andy i feel like we are actually getting
the moment that all of us wanted which
was you out of that car and into our
dreams
as the billy ocean song goes
don't cry don't cry no don't cry i love
it
oh it's so meaningful oh he's going to
make me cry now stop
may i
may i ask what's going through your head
and heart
we've just been through so lot you know
my mom was single parent and so
for us to get to this position
it's not easy
she's working three jobs
little play tennis into the best schools
so like doing even things like
graduation
it's not just me walking across the
stage she's there with me
being on the stage it just whether she
showed up or not she's always with me
and to be able to do this
in front of everybody just
hit me so much
[Applause]
i think he means set the bar for love
[Music]